hello
another second press conference
today with the president madam 30
in hatred and the commissioner in charge
sings health madam dhalla kyriakides s
on the communication that the commission
adopted this morning concerning
the commission's response to the end of the thousand
hills
des margalla
[Music]
chris mogan five days
and we know it's not
very old
and we have where it's done it's in
new street is again in the micro
gibbs in microwave help mean i
want to sing south african  willie like
honda hm honda transparency
and started to find and the green it
because every single
situation at the
microphone
before 8am at
10.229 the building variants badr enough
to be concerned you write about
you take that might be here we know more
experience with the blind date were  by
our side
any other
xxl as we share with you got what kind of
aurélie and must vaccinate j in the mouth
provide the struggling
10 drop protection against any kind
of being sorry w  e shall we will use in
fine all in one vaccination consult
in
your soul fans
of sofac
syntagma
and except
modern accident in bayonne czech form 10
6 million 12 th art never seen
the end of the
twenty two 10 and safe and are crazy
madness vaccinate
but
the
last but not least in case of and
situation where we see dead omicron and
zinor fully responding to vaccination we
have also corner images inline
[Music]